що стосується Донбасу то звісно там таке
концентроване горе вони це роблять
спеціально вони просто знищують
населення Донбасу це якесь просто
божевільне тупе знищення заради знищення
те що Росія пішла відкритою війною це і
є такий жествіччю це вони розписалися в
тому що вони не змогли
зіграти Скажімо так в інформаційному
полі це навіть не можна назвати
мобілізацію Це вбивство Це просто масове
вбивство а потім дуже зручно їм показати
що Дивіться це ж Україна стріляла це
значить Україна вбила їх от там це от
поки його в Зеленський зробив
Денис Казанський український журналіст
блогер автор двох книжок про Донбас
Денис жив і висвітлював події у своєму
рідному Донецьку до 2014 року а останні
вісім років Денис розповідає про Донбас
вже з Києва де ми з ним власне і
зустрілися Вітаю Дениса
перше питання з приводу Росії і того що
вона частково над зусиллями але все ж
досягла якихось своїх цілей на Донбасі
які настрої у місцевого населення у
захоплених містах що вони пишуть про що
хвилюються А що стосується Донбасу то
звісно там таке концентроване горе тому
що ми можемо умовно поділити Донбас та
на дві частини це українська де
відбуваються бойові дії і де фактично
Росія повністю знищує все життя вона
знищує міста через які проходить
російська армія Вона нікого не жаліє і
практично вже казати про повернення туди
нормального життя Мені здається
найближчі роки просто неможливо щоб вони
не казали вони там обіцяють відновити
Маріуполь но враховуючи в якому він
стані навіть якщо вони щось відновлять
ну повністю це відновити неможливо за
короткий період І власне і сам Путін там
колись місяць тому казав що на
відновлення підуть роки ну зрозуміло що
це як знаєте ішака или падішак тобто не
буде відновлення а деякі міста вони вже
офіційно кажуть що не будуть
відновлювати взагалі наприклад папасно
попасно заявив Да От цей говоряйтер
Пасічник що вони не будуть відновлювати
вона на 90% зруйнована ну тобто Уявіть
собі жили люди і повністю зруйнували все
що в них було життя майно нічого не
залишилося буде просто пустеля і уламки
оці руїни в пустелі в степу і Ну як ви
думаєте можуть люди ставитися до Росії
ну відповідно є якийсь відсоток фріків
маргіналів які можуть незважаючи ні на
що казати що це велика Росія матушка але
більшість в принципі нормальних людей
адекватних психічно здорових вони
розуміють що це відбувається Просто
злочин Росія фактично здійснює геноцид
мешканців Донбасу і стирає взагалі з
землі сандонбас як регіон як середовище
яке ідентичність от певна Да яка
сформувалася в цих місцях цього немає а
щодо тоді на непідконтрольних територіях
які окуповані з 2014 року там ситуація
інша там немає таких руйнувань тому що
незважаючи на те що російська пропаганда
нам розповідала що 8 років страшно
Україна обстрілює Донбас нічого
подібного не відбувалося там люди живуть
в принципі Ну більш-менш якоїсь
стабільної ситуації але все одно це ну
по-перше
це існування в умовах
дуже в Великих злиднів тобто ну
економічного занепаду А по-друге що
найстрашніше там зараз відбувається і що
зачіпляє фактично кожну родину це оця
варварська мобілізація така хижацька
коли просто людей викрадають на вулицях
і
відправляють ну фактично на смерть і
через це люди Ну вони жахливо просто
обурені вони дуже не згодні з тим що
відбувається
Я бачу там просто величезну от хвилю
такого хейту ненависті до Росії але
водночас це не створює якусь любов до
України Тобто Це просто таке життя у
вічі що
і на сході і на півдні Україні є
наводчики які допомагають ЗСУ але також
є колаборанти і ось наскільки це явище
воно на Донбасі поширено було за останні
пів року Скажімо так наскільки поширено
Якщо ми будемо дивитися у відсотках до
населення якщо у відсотках до місцевих
політиків і керівників це трохи різні
речі да тому що Ну якщо брати у
відсотках до населення в усього в цілому
то Звісно це просто ну одиниця це
невеличкий відсоток тому що Ну хто пішов
в колаборанти там 50 співробітників
поліції а 30 співробітників якогось там
міськвиконкому місцями це може бути мир
але в меншості міст наприклад да потому
что все ж таки в більшості захоплених
міст місцева Влада настала співпрацювати
вона виїхала А це окремі міста Ну
все-тагірську там погодився в рубіжному
погодався мер наприклад Маріуполі з
усього депутатського корпусу всієї
міськради погодилися там кілька оцих
депутатів від опзж а тому це в принципі
Ну скажімо Так точно не те на що
розраховувала Російська Федерація коли
вони казали що їх будуть зустрічати з
квітами що всі вийдуть там їм не ключі
від міста принесуть там хліб-сіль такого
немає і близько Тобто їм доводиться
майже всюди находити людей які ну
скажемо так абсолютно не користувалися
жодним авторитетом не мали ну фактично
скажемо так ніякого
ніякої влади і просто вони їх там зараз
призначають просто як вивіску щоб
показати що Хоч хтось за них але ну
фактично Всі розуміють що це зовсім не
те На що вони розраховували і в
більшості в більшості населення на
Донбасі проти хоча Всі казали пропаганди
казали що Донбас він тотально
проросійський це виявилося абсолютно не
так чогось Питали про кола
бораційний сприймають інакше ніж на
півдні типу що на півдні або на півночі
Коли це було їх більше радо вітали ніж
зараз я розумію що деякі там солдати
коли вони з цим стикаються їм неприємно
вони можуть про це писати однак є разом
з тими такі люди які точно не хочуть
ніякої ЛНР ДНР Ну просто
це величезна кількість таких людей Вони
зараз виїхали Вони знаходяться тут тих
там видно да Ці машини там з донецькими
з луганськими номерами У мене вже в
дворі навіть встигли кафе відкрити
переселенці з Рубіжного підприємця які в
яких там зазначили ну нормальна людина
не може це підтримувати Тобто Ну
зрозумійте да тому що Ну от життя в
умовах коли тобі просто зруйнували місто
невідомо коли відновлять і чи відновлять
його взагалі і
ти живеш невідомо Де ти громадянин не
існуючої типу якогось утворення питання
тобі надали якісь паспорти який він
навіть виглядає цей паспорт ЛНР він як
ну сувенірний Тобто ти обереш він як він
не справжній він з такого паперу
зроблено погано і ну це не може
нормально
сприймати тому звісно є така такий
відсоток людей Вони Як правило це
маргінали от я бачу відео звідти там як
сидять якісь там люди пиячать от вони
там гора Росія прийшла от такі от п'яні
там вже такі
такі люди теж є Да От і думаю що коли і
по скільки вони яскраві Да От як коли їх
знімають на відео це викликає обурення
це відео починають репостити і людям
може здаватися що у Да От їх багато
тобто вони їм потрапляють такі відео і
вони роблять такі висновки А всі такі не
всі от зовсім інакше справа насправді
там але ті хто залишається це ті хто за
ті хто ж як кажуть ждуни які чекають все
ж російську армію чи чому взагалі Люди
зараз залишається в цих зруйнованих
містах ви знаєте є різні люди дійсно
хтось залишається тому що прямо от чекає
хоче щоб росіяни прийшли
мале залишається і ті люди які от просто
це якесь ірраціональне рішення от є
просто такий Скажімо так вид людей які
просто кажуть оце моє місто я звідси
нікуди не поїду Це мій дом от якщо його
розмовляють значить нехай Я загину мені
нема куди їхати і все одно от завтра
буде Україна сьогодні Росія післязавтра
навіть якщо хтось інший вони от все одно
тут залишиться тобто є і такі люди Ну я
можу сказати що взагалі тих хто
залишається їх меншість Тобто Чим би
вони не керувалися таких людей меншість
і
в основному Ну от зараз на Донеччині Да
там кажуть що залишилося близько 300 000
людей а було населення там умовно кажучи
ну на на початок всі повномасштабної
агресії на підконтрольній частині це
десь 2 млн 300 000 просто 2 мільйони
десь евакуювалися І от меншість
залишилася а може
бути Ну безумовно Це є просто Ну я думаю
що навіть ті хто їдуть звісно ну Уявіть
собі все ж таки більше ж людей на
Донбасі Я думаю що не тільки на Донбасі
Ну а там Це точно так вони нікуди не
виїжджали взагалі Ну от люди які живуть
цих невеличких селищах Вони ж там не
їздять там за кордоном Вони ніколи не
були вони більшість з них не були
наприклад ніколи на Західній Україні
тобто вони живуть якимось міфами про те
що там відбувається
на місцях Ви дізнаєтеся з відкритих
джерел цих чатів в телеграмі і все Чи у
вас є якісь джерела в основному з
відкритих є звісно і Мої особисті
джерела закриті які не можу називати Ну
але я з тих джерел ту інформацію яку я
маю я її більше там для себе та тому що
я розумію що якщо я напишу що от мені
там сказала людина яку я не називаю що
от так воно і так то довір'я такої
інформації не буде Зараз ми живемо в
епоху інтернету і якщо немає профів як
то кажуть немає фото цьому відео скрінів
цього не було тому ту інформацію яку я
отримав від людей які там живуть я її
для себе розумію а вони мені там часто
можуть підказати де пошукати да Що
подивитися А ви дуже багато там прізвище
використовуєте пишете там трішки
іроність обоє ви витримуєте якісь
погрози так постійно це ж не залежить
від стьоби іронії просто в будь-яка
людина яка пише щось незручне для росіян
і для їх окупаційних адміністрацій вона
буде отримувати погрози Ну як це
виглядає розумієте теж Ну це погрози там
в коментарях в інтернеті в якихось
особистих повідомленнях тобто ну з 14-го
року Так я отримав такий повідомлення
час від часу я вже дав Ну просто до них
звик і я вже просто не звертаюся уваги А
хто цілював аудиторія вашого блогу тому
що по деяким месенджерам враження що це
не для проукраїнських українців для
когось іншого про українську українські
українці звісно дивляться і коментують і
все просто ну звертатися до них мені
нема що їм доводити бо вони як правило
все саме самі чудове розуміють і бачать
Я часто звертаюся до людей так які може
є не проукраїнські або
Ну скажімо так не розуміють що
відбувається такі знаєте неоднозначні от
вони подивилися там подивилися тут тобто
таких треба ще переконати да а тому що
так Ну я свою місію там як журналіст і
публіцист бачив в тому щоб ну довести
людям да переконати тих хто вірив в
якийсь там деструктивні антиукраїнські
ідеї а тому що да тих кого не треба
переконувати ну умовно кажучи Так я чому
там російською да введу в основному
блогер Ну що я розумію що я ну не не
варто переконувати мешканців там чи
Дрогобича там все добре Я да звертаюся в
тому числі до
людей на Донбасі до білорусів до казахів
у мене До речі велику територія чомусь
Казахстану А ви відчуваєте якісь фідбек
що є якісь суф от ви кажете що хочете
змінити думку чи якихось людей Ви це
відчуваєте що вам дається тому та й
справа Що нам Ну не тільки мені там
власно нам українцям скажемо так
українським журналістам в нас нам як
суспільство вдалося трансформувати
суспільну думку в Україні і насправді от
те що Росія пішла відкритою війною це і
є такий жест-двічі це вони розписалися в
тому що вони не змогли
зіграти скажемо так в інформаційному
полі тобто в м'яку силу Да в смарт Power
тобто вони не витримали цієї конкуренції
в їхні Вони ж теж не заряджали якихось
там е лідерів думок у них телеканали
працювали куплені медведчуківські да
вони ж всі працювали на те щоб наша
аудиторію переконати що Росія не ворог
що треба там домовлятися визнати ЛНР там
Ну от ці всі народитиви і їм не вдалося
вони просто от на цьому інформаційному
полі вони програли і саме тому Путін ну
фактично впав в цю історію і просто від-
відлюті від
бажання помститися він і розпочав
фактично цю війну якщо казати про
публічну думку чому тоді такі цей меседж
Где вы были 8 лет Так разлетився чому
його підхопили і він такий став
популярний Ну по-перше він розлетівся де
він розлетівся в Російській Федерації
тому що це російське суспільство йому
цей меседж вдається вдалим по-друге цей
меседж Ну як то кажуть форсався да є
таке поняття тобто коли є мережа
проплачених блогерів там державних
телеканалів
змій і всі постійно постять цей меседж
Ну звісно він буде всюди це ж Росія їм
здається що це зручно що це вдало от
вони так закинули хоча Насправді це дуже
невдало І взагалі Ну давайте подивимося
як українська армія в 14-му році
звільняла ті самі міста як за яких
сьогодні йде бій і подивіться що з ними
робить російська армія українська аж
армія В 14-му році в липні звільнила
наприклад там Сєвєродонецьк там
Лисичанськ навіть якісь там трохи були
вуличні бої Ну і що там два два чи три
там будинки були пошкоджені десь там дах
знесло десь побилися вікна впав стовп
згоріла заправка це все зараз цих міст
просто немає от северодонецька його
немає там вони називали цифри це
російські оці окупанти що там 800
будинків там з чимось було
багатоквартирних жилих а з них там 4 400
зруйновані тут половина міста немає от
це різниця як діє українська армія яка
начебто обстрілювала в 8 років і як
робить російська армія яка начебто як
вони кажуть
спасає Донбас помогает донбассу как
Путин говорил да помогаем жить нам
Донбасса там освобождаемых защищаем ну
Дякуємо Якщо говорити про цю масову
мобілізацію в
лднр
Ось вона впли
ває на чи вся критика йде на місцеву
владу Ну я дивлюся по коментарях
коментарі зазвичай дуже негативні просто
вот люди вони просто от знаєте Ну сача
це ненавистю з них вона просто йде
привід вони ненавидять всіх і Хтось пише
Да що це от значить в Росії просто не
знаю це там от пушилін щоб вислужитися
він це робить наганяє цих просто
нещасних людей надає накази щоб їх там
ловили на вулицях відправляли на фронт
хтось каже що ні пушилін там Пасічник
нічого не вирішують це з Москви так
сказали робити Ну в принципі всі
по-різному кажуть ну всі в принципі
навіть ті хто є люди які просто не
хочуть цього визнати навіть якщо вони це
розуміють бо це означає визнати що ти
помилився що ти все у що ти вірив
виявилося помилкою що ти вірив в людей
тобі вважалося що це вдалі ідеї а вони
виявилися люди жерарами не всі здатні на
це да визнати що вони помилялися і тому
багато людей просто намагається якось ну
відігнати від себе цю думку але те що
там відбувається це саме геноцид
чоловічого населення це навіть не можна
назвати мобілізацію тому що мобілізація
передбачає певні правила і процедури вас
якщо мобілізують вот в Україні да
приходить повістка Ви маєте з'явитися
військомат вас не можуть викрасти на
вулиці Да ви проходите медкомісію якщо у
вас там Вибачте там Ну якийсь хвороби
там Порок серця чи психічні розлади таке
ж теж багато там люди в них там діагноз
шизофренія їх не можна Їх не не візьмуть
на фронт і вони просто непридатні чи
якщо там три дитини в людини її на
мобілізують там це все одно хочу в тебе
10 дітей хочете шизофренік хоч в тебе
там я не знаю там ну там букет хвороб
там туберкульоз просто схопили на вулиці
і без медогляду без підготовки просто
вот на тебе там берданку винтовку Мосина
автомат Калашникова як тобі пощастить Це
вбивство Це просто масове вбивство тому
що людина яка не прийшла медогляд хвора
яка не має підготовки не знає як
стріляти немає ніяких навичок і
відправляти під Гради під кулі е-е на
такі самі розпечені ділянки фронту це
майже гарантована або загибель або
каліцтво вони це роблять спеціально вони
просто знищують населення Донбасу а
потім дуже зручно їм показати що
Дивіться це ж Україна стріляла це
значить Україна вбила їх от там це от
покидьок Зеленський Зробив те що робить
Росія з Донбасом Ну я думаю що
прецеденти в історії були бо історія
довгими не все знаємо але ну в новітній
історії в історії європейських держав Ну
я такого не можу пригадати це якесь
просто божевільне тупе Знищення заради
знищення
тому що у людей з так званих Hell ДНР
немає прав фактично можете розкрити цю
думку абсолютно абсолютно немає прав в
14-му році він забрали всі в принципі
базові права вони не можуть збиратися на
мітинги там чогось вимагати якщо мітинг
Це не той що організований владою
ЛНР так званої то тоді одразу оголошують
що ти Агент України це робиться Що
просто качати ситуацію і людей саджають
на підвал в тебе немає права там на
забастовку немає право на свободу слова
ну це можна навіть не розкривати не
пояснювати це всі знають немає права
вибору тобто в людей відібрали право
обирати навіть Ну депутата сільради Там
вже немає місцева Влада вся
призначається це гагуляйтери це ти ті
кого призначає Росія вони не залежать
від населення відповідно їм байдуже що
там населення не так да вони сидять щоб
задовольнити тих тих поставив тобто своє
начальство
ну взагалі немає жодних прав ну або чи є
там Правосуддя чи є адвокати Да якщо
можуть когось завгодно викрасти посадити
в підвал просто тримати взимдані там на
ямі е-е і куди ти скажешся там нема
нічого немає опозиції немає журналістів
нема міжнародних організацій немає
правозахисників все в цьому Ну звісно це
би така територія абсолютно
безправ'я де От такі на рівні Ну от
африканських якихось бантостанів у людей
Скажімо так да отставлення до до людей
до місцевого населення
постили те що люди починають помічати що
виходи десь дуже поруч А ось і включно з
цієї мобілізацією і відсутністю права
там відбувається якийсь суд там не
відбувається такого сулу який можна було
помітити тобто люди вони точно не
задоволені тим що там відбувається
Колосальне незадоволені Ну тому що ну
фактично ж все що їм там обіцяли да от
заради чого починали цю війну загостину
фазу Їм же казали що це щоб безпека
мешканців Донбасу ми Захистимо людей Ну
і що сталося тобто фактично тепер
реально Донецьк підостріми якщо там вони
казали бомбілі 8 лет насправді не
бомбили То тепер дійсно бомблять і з
різних боків Ну давайте казати відверто
і з'ясу теж наносять удари по об'єктах
різних там військових складах чи
будівлях де знаходяться сидять самі ці
бойовики по їхніх там казармах штабах А
є інші обстріли коли стріляють самі
бойовики Я не знаю навіщо вони це
роблять може для жесточення може навіть
може просто помилково І таке може бути
враховуючи як вони там стріляють но
просто є кілька моментів які розбирали
які доведені де снаряди потрапляють
наприклад в будинки лише збоку де
російські війська і українські не можуть
ніяк
прострілити в цю там
південно-східну сторону Да яка
направлена просто вот в бік де тільки з
14-го року стоять росіяни А є багато
прильотів де люди прям фіксують Міна в
центрі міста міномет не добиває з
українських позицій в центр міста тобто
приліт невеличкої Міна невеличкого
калібру Це точно не з українських
позицій звідки ніхто не може сказати
останнє питання Ви вірите що Донбас
повернеться повністю Україні і що у вас
буде стрім з вашого рідного Донецька ви
знаєте я повірив Це тепер Да я думав
воно вже так останні роки там десь 20-21
Воно вже Все йшло до того що я так
розумію що ми маємо якийсь
придністровський варіант якусь там
Абхазію що це буде от на десятиліття
воно зараз повністю заморозиться і десь
так і пройде але після того як Путін сам
все загострив він підняв і питання Криму
знову і питання Донбасу і якщо тоді він
так це на гальмах спускав і йому на
найголовніше да давала міжнародна
спільнота спускати це на гальмах і ми
йшли до того що Україна втрачала Крим
Донбас фактично всі так змирилися з цим
да То тепер він сам актуалізував
втрачати більше нічого тобто на інший
казали ну як повертати крім він Крим
війною це ж ві- воювати з Росією як ми
на це не підемо А зараз ми воюємо з
Росією тому що в нас просто немає виходу
він сам це
і тоді вже чому ні а що нам заважає да а
те ж саме стосується Донбасу Тобто ми
розуміємо що вже так воно просто не
скінчиться що в Росії душать санкціями
російські режим Я думаю що Ну рано чи
пізно цей маразм він не може тривати
нескінченно він просто завалиться Тобто
там буде якесь перезавантаження
стосунків з усім цивілізованим світом і
це буде передбачати повернення Україні
наших територій Дуже дякую вам тоді за
розмову